To say Jordan Spieth gets it may be an understatement.
But with two wins in his last two starts,...
...it's safe to say the 21-year-old is clearly one of the game's future stars.
Jordan is 39 under par in his last eight competitive rounds,...
...including a final-round 63 to capture the Australian Open...
...and a wire-to-wire 10-shot victory at the Hero World Challenge.
The Texan hosted the inaugural Jordan Spieth Shootout and Charity concert,...
...which helped raise awareness for his three key areas of philanthropic concern:...
...junior golf, military families and special needs youths.
The inspiration behind the foundation is Ellie Spieth, Jordan's younger sister.
Ellie was born with neurological challenges...
...and is a constant source of motivation for Jordan.
I'm her biggest fan, she's my biggest fan.
Mentally, she's learning to do new things and it really is something that's incredible...
...and something that I wish a lot of people have the chance to experience.
Maybe they can through this event and through the Spieth Family Foundation.
Every time I step on the tee, I believe I have a chance to win that week.
You gotta go in with utmost confidence in order to compete at PGA Tour...
...and so I'd like to get a couple of wins...
...and I think that that can happen and make it the best year yet.